vous êtes 100 milles sur ma chaîne
youtube plus 23000 parce que le temps
que je fasse cette vidéo en fait
maintenant vous êtes 123000 je voulais
la faire pour les cent mille mais j'ai
un peu raté le coche après je voulais
vous annoncer des choses mais du coup ça
me fait encore plus plaisir
et en plus si youtube va envoyer ce
petit cadeau voilà ça c'est vous là
c'est vous donc c'est super sympa avec
une petite lettre pour dire bravo
j'ai pas encore lequel dd je vais
accrocher en fait c'est quoi à dire mais
c'est cool d'avoir un objet matériel qui
symbolise parce que sinon c'est quoi
céder des chiffres c'est des pages web
c'est des fichiers c'est important
d'avoir de temps en temps il ya un
ancrage réel quoi c'est comme quand on
se voit dans la vraie vie tu as les
conventions les choses comme ça donc
c'est cool parce que voilà
man je veux vous remercier d'être aussi
nombreux ça fait énormément plaisir
voilà c'est même pas une question de
chimie attendais pas je m'y attendais
non c'est juste qu'en fait ça fait
plaisir quoi ça fait plaisir d'avoir
voilà il ya deux ans et demi j'ai j'ai
lancé ce projet j'étais tout seul j'ai
mis beaucoup d'efforts et de bonne
volonté
donc ça fait plaisir de voir que j'ai
réussi à assembler les gens autour de ça
ça intéresse des gens qui ont
possiblement appris des choses ou en
tous cas j'espère passer un bon et rien
que ça voilà c'est c'est ouf
et quand je vous croise dans la rue et
tout à chaque fois c'est si bienveillant
des fois j'ai des conversations
intéressantes et trouve c'est génial
c'est génial et donc voilà je voulais
sincèrement vous remercier quoi mais je
profite de cette vidéo pour vous dire
quelques trucs hyper important d'abord
je lance une newsletter
alors qu'est ce que ça fait c'est un
mail que vous recevrez une fois par
semaine ou une fois par mois au début ça
risque d'être une fois par mois le temps
que je comprenne vraiment comment ça
marche bien et qui me mettre dedans bien
et ce mail eva récapituler plein de
trucs intéressants qui sont passés des
trucs intéressants des news des
découvertes des articles des réflexions
plein de trucs pour ceux qui me suivent
sur facebook
d'ailleurs vous êtes bientôt vingt mille
et ça tue bah vous voyez exactement ce
que je veux dire je pense c'est genre
par exemple cette semaine j'ai partagé
une conférence ted qui vous a d'ailleurs
pas mal plus eh bien c'est ce genre de
choses alors il suffit d'aller sur cyrus
net.com vous balancez votre adresse et
voilà ça y est alors évidemment votre
adresse je la fais la personne on est
d'accord et vous pouvez vous désabonner
en un clic qui sera dans le mail et si
vous voulez vous pouvez vous réabonner
derrière hyper easy et ce sera aussi le
moyen pour moi de vous annoncer des
trucs importants par exemple par rapport
à des projets ou des nouveautés alors je
le dis parce qu'on a posé la question
sur périscope parce que je lui ai
annoncé un peu pour voir ce que les gens
à penser évidemment ce sera gratos pour
vous en tout cas moi ça me coûte un peu
mais ça fait plaisir vraiment parce que
c'est un projet qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment un truc que je kifferais avoir
dans la boîte mail
du coup bah je
le fait j'espère que ça vous plaît
ensuite youtube a enfin annoncé les sous
titres collaboratif en france donc ça
défonce et en rond concrètement serre
que vous pouvez contribuer à faire des
sous titres sur une vidéo et ce qui est
fou c'est que je les ai même pas encore
annoncé jeu sur aucune plateforme ayez
déjà des gens qui ont fait des sous
titres alors je te camille d'eau sur
hegel
elle a sous titré en français sa défense
un merci beaucoup et vous en parle parce
que je sais que vous êtes cultivé et que
parmi vous il ya plein de gens qui
parlent plusieurs langues et donc ça
serait génial
avant les autres langues déjà le
français pour nos amis malentendants ça
ce serait top
alors en plus nous français on n'est pas
mal en fils on aime on a de bons
philosophe avec nous ce serait pas mal
de montrer aux anglais et aux allemands
que ils peuvent rentrer chez eux de quoi
que le youtube français est au dessus du
game en philo ça serait pas mal
la même passion son plan de sa
accessible aux brésiliens aux chinois
aux espagnols enfin ce serait je serai
demain alors qu on soustrait une vidéo
c'est très simple en fait il suffit
d'aller sur la vidéo goulet et sur la
barre de lecture il ya une petite roue
dentée la sévère ou de paramètres ou
cliqué dessus sous titres ajoutés sous
titres et c'est parti mon kiki
du coup voilà si vous voulez sous-titré
une vidéo vous pouvez y aller
et si jamais vous le faites je pense que
c'est mieux de commencer par les coups
de fil parce que c'est dans ces épisodes
là qu'est le plus de connaissances de
connaissances brut et donc c'est ce qui
pourrait intéresser potentiellement plus
les étrangers
et les français mais en attendant c'est
plus utile en fait dernière chose je
lance un conte tipi alors pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas vous voyez le
financement participatif
alors c'est totalement l'inversé parce
que en fait de financement participatif
tu va financer un projet pour qu'il
existe hockey par exemple khroma est
bien là celle inverse pascal projet luxe
déjà c'est ma chaîne et c'est financé
par mois bas par exemple avec mon matos
caméra d'ailleurs je passe vous avez vu
mes jeunes un peu améliorée jean ya des
fois il ya deux caméras sur certains
épisodes genre sur les popotes et où je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu bref y aussi
des prestataires genre du graphisme pour
des logos etc ou certaines munich et
aussi du développement informatique
non ça c'est mon projet pour le coup
mais y'a du décor aussi leur juste comme
ça
micro enfin bref pas mal de trucs qui du
coup sont ma responsabilité et c'est mon
projet donc c'est normal que le finance
et puis ça prend du temps du temps que
je pourrai consacrée à des clients par
exemple sachant que du temps ben il n'en
reste pas beaucoup parce que j'ai déjà
un taf quoi donc
donc voilà tout ça c'est mon projet et
ça me permet de vous faire des vidéos
gratos que je pense j'espère sont
crédités quoi ses buts mais avec tipis
jeu vous permet de soutenir tout ça
différemment que par un like ou un
partage ce qui est déjà un très très bon
soutien qu'on soit d'accord donc tipi
c'est un système qui vous permet de
soutenir financièrement un créateur et
c'est un système qu'on retrouve dans
plein de pays du monde et en france
hélas pas mal de créateurs déjà qu'ils
sont sûrs depuis en plus pas mal de
temps du coup pour savoir si vous devez
donner un créateur je peux reprendre les
3 questions
de mon collègue brousse qui sont bas 1
est-ce que son boulot justifie une
rétribution
2 est ce que vous voulez soutenir ce
créateur et 3 ce qui est hyper important
est ce que vous pouvez vous le permettre
parce que quoi que je fasse chier en
fait faut que ce soit par plaisir c'est
le plus beau l'ontarien pure et ya
aucune différence entre ce que pour moi
entre quelqu'un qui donne et qui donnent
pas d'argent il va rien se passer c'est
la même chose pour tout le monde donc en
fait ce projet là c'est mon projet c'est
c'est mon envie c'est ma décision c'est
mes coups ces montants mais du coup si
vous voulez maintenant donne un coup de
pouce au lieu de donner un coup de fil
et bien vous pouvez voilà et si en plus
après ça me permet de dégager du temps
pour me mettre encore plus ce serait
génial
par contre je ne savais pas que ça
change notre relation voilà ça c'est
hyper important pour moi c'est pour ça
que c'est vraiment du volontariat quoi
et je n'ai pas annoncé avant parce que
je voulais pas vous l'annoncé alors que
vous étiez 20000 et vous le rappeler
tous les quatre matins quoi alors j'ai
préféré attendre que vous soyez peu
nombreux et vous l'annoncé d'un coup et
si je vous en reparle
ça passe au dessus de quoi l'idée c'est
l'idée c'est ça donc voilà je vous ai
tout dit inscrivez-vous à la newsletter
c'est le second truc le plus important
de cette vidéo le premier c'est merci
voilà
ensuite si vous voulez faire un des sous
titres des sous à les y voilà
et checker le tipi et je vous envoie
beaucoup love chao bébé